country music's biggest stars returned
to las vegas last night for the 57th
annual academy of country music awards
and let me just say it didn't disappoint
from the fashion to the performances and
history-making wins we need to break it
all down
yes so for the first time ever the show
was held at allegiant stadium hosted by
the one and only dolly parton along with
rising stars gabby barrett and jimmy
allen among some of the notable winners
old dominion took home group of the year
for the fifth year in a row
carly pierce earned female artist of the
year and miranda lambert won the biggest
honor of the night entertainer of the
year for the first time that's right it
was definitely a really great night for
the ladies but morgan wallen
who sparked debate after winning album
of the year for dangerous the double
album one year after his major
controversy morgan was banned from the
acms in 2021 after he was caught on
camera in a leaked video using a racial
racial slur
yeah so morgan was also pulled from
several radio stations and suspended
from his record label in addition he was
deemed ineligible at the 2021 cmt awards
banned from the 2021 billboard music
awards and banned from any
non-collaborative categories at the cma
awards morgan has since apologized on
several occasions and appeared on good
morning america back in the summer where
he revealed he checked into a rehab
center after the incident now morgan
released the album in january of 2021
just weeks before all the controversy
the album has gone on to make history
spending more weeks in the top 10 of the
billboard 200 chart than any other
country album ever a record previously
held by taylor swift
yeah while morgan received loud cheers
inside the stadium not everyone was in
support of the win with maren morris
reportedly refusing to applaud or stand
up for the singer mind you i saw the
clip and she did see here's the clip
right here so she could see she's in a
conversation and then very faint in the
back you see her clapping so i don't
know
where all the rumors are coming from but
many disappointed twitter users claim
the win suggests that racism is
celebrated in country music while others
pointed out that morgan apologized and
shouldn't have to sacrifice his career
here's what morgan had to say during his
acceptance speech
when i started this album
i was a kid
by the time i put it out i was a father
and that's become more important to me
than anything else
to my son this album and this award will
signify that his daddy was a fighter and
then he chased his dreams and worked
hard to make them a reality i'd also
like to thank my good lord and savior
jesus christ my family
my close friends
my band
my team in nashville country radio and
everyone who has shown me grace along
the way
now fellow country singer hardy spoke
with entertainment tonight shortly after
the win admitting he cried when he heard
morgan's name he explained
it means a lot for him he works very
hard he deserves that award for those
who don't know your peers or
co-workers vote for who should win this
award hardy added that everybody
deserves a second chance deserves a
chance to fight for themselves and
that's exactly what's happened so this
was bigger than that award for him it
meant a lot and i'm very proud of him
yeah um i mean listen first of all award
shows in general are a lot of politics
you know payola friends of friends this
person you know awards don't really it
just seems like the country music world
has forgiven morgan wallin oh at least
these awards have forgiven morgan wall
and i'd be interested to see what other
award shows are gonna do like the
billboards the grammys things like that
um
i just
racism has always been a thing in
country music unfortunately and so has
sexism like you see a lot of women
country singers um they don't get the
same amount of play on radio stations
they don't get this the same amount of
love as their male counterparts so
there's a lot of like issues in country
music i mean i'm sure a lot of genres
have issues but
at this point i'll be honest with you i
was actually surprised morgan got
cancelled
to begin with because country music
yeah because i'm like
i didn't think country music uh as a
whole really cared too much about
something like this to be quite honest
with you i was shocked that they took a
stance i mean it only lasted 10 months
um but you know it's it's tough i feel
like
i believe in country i believe in cancel
culture when there's racism when there's
sexism when there's just you know
discrimination when there's violence
when there's things like that i feel
like people need to be checked and need
to be humbled and be held accountable
but i also believe in the power of
forgiveness and things being a teachable
moment i don't know if morgan
has learned anything i don't know i
don't know him personally i just know
that he has apologized i found the
apologies to be insincere um but i don't
know it's one of those things like i'm
not god i can't judge him i i don't know
what he's learned i
yeah the whole situation is just
wild but i get why people are mad and i
get why people are supporting him so i
don't know what are you thinking
you're like i can see this and i can see
listen what i would have liked
i like that he went away to rehab and he
took a beat to learn and to hopefully
grow listen what what i really wanted to
see when he was up there in that speech
is to talk a little bit about what
you've learned and how you've grown
because that was a really great
opportunity to speak out and to speak up
and to be humble and to talk about where
you've changed and i wanted i wanted to
see that so but again time will tell
right you talk about giving people the
room to grow and be better i want i want
people in this world advocating for
everyone and to grow if we push them
under a rock and they get you know i
don't want i want more people
spreading love and doing good things and
if he's willing to do that and be out in
the world and be a part of that that's
what i want to see
but he should have done that when he
gave a
speech you know
yeah i do agree i think it would have
been nice for him i mean he didn't have
to make the whole speech about that
moment but it would have been nice if he
said you know you know this is a
celebration for all my fans and and how
far i've come or something on those
lines where you're like ah you know
where you kind of want to root for him
yes but it's just one of those things
like i understand cancel culture but at
the same time i'm like how long do we
cancel a person and and who judges
if they've learned or not if they've if
they if they're remorseful like how do
we even merit that so the whole thing is
just insane but at the end of the day
it's an award show it's politics i mean
i don't know if i care about awards as
much as anything you know
um fair enough yeah that's my thought